good afternoon film courage Karen David
and all the rest my name is Josh Tom
Jack I'm 22 years old I'm a college
student and I'm an aspiring filmmaker
I've been writing seriously for about
three or four years storytelling has
always been something that's lit a fire
within me ever since I was a young kid
but hasn't been until recently that I
really started to understand the career
possibilities that kind of go along with
that and I really haven't looked back
since my current script I've been
working on it for about eight or nine
months now it's called the it girl it's
about you know one young man's journey
of quite literally trying to turn his
fantasy into reality by thrusting
himself into an acting career you know
with no experience whatsoever and no
desire really you know because his sole
intention his sole purpose is to meet
into court you know the only woman who
he deems to be worth his time his only
purpose is to is to achieve this fantasy
and of course this dream woman happens
to be you know one of the most famous
most popular actresses in Hollywood and
like I said I've been polishing it
revising it putting it through the
wringer for about nine months now
closing in on a year but it's an
exciting process it's exciting for me
because it has so much to offer me and I
think it has so much to offer other
people as well it's such a self
reflective process writing and in this
case it's it deals with you know the
theists theme that that we all struggle
with this this idea of self-imposed
expectations this idea of dreams ideals
fantasies you know in trying to turn
them into reality you know the harsh
truth is it's incredibly difficult to
turn these these ideas of happiness and
satisfaction these assurances that we
have within ourselves of what it's going
to take to make us happy it's extremely
difficult to turn these things into
reality to make these things come to
fruition and that's a process that I've
been battling my entire life you know
the pressure that we put on ourselves
you know the character in this story his
absolute worst fear is settling for a
life that underwhelms him it isn't that
all of our fears you know we all have
this idea we all have this clear picture
exactly what it's going to take whether
it's a career or otherwise you know
whatever it may be we have we know so
clearly exactly what it's going to take
to make us happy and satisfied but the
interesting fascinating bit is you know
these things they tend to evolve as we
do you know just a simple look at the
past will tell you that and I think this
is fascinating this is what we all go
through and this is what my characters
go through in this story and I believe
in this and this is why I you know I I
don't want to give up on the script
because I believe in this message I
believe that universally people connect
can connect with this struggle you know
this this inner pressure that we have on
ourselves to reach our own expectations
to achieve these dreams in these
fantasies and to deal with not achieving
them you know an understanding ourselves
but on a more pragmatic level you know
the script is just a testament to me the
characters in this story are going
through so many similar processes that
I'm going through internally and
externally and in the script has kind of
just been a testament of what it means
to take action on a regular basis what
it means to be disciplined what it means
to work towards your goals you know
because obviously that's what the
characters are doing you know and it
kind of rien spires that in me it
reminds me of that that's why I don't
want to give it up I guess then I'll
move into kind of a lesson that writing
has taught me and this is not
necessarily just for this script but
just in general as I've been writing for
the last four years or so you know I've
come to understand people a little bit
deeper and I know that's kind of broad
to say but you know when you're writing
and crafting characters as real people
you start to understand the world on a
less egotistical level you know we all
live our lives in our own you know with
the blinders on in our own worlds
focused on what we want what we need but
when you're creating characters you
begin to understand I guess on a more
empathetic level that we're all so
similar you know that we all have
desires we all have inspiration we all
have passion you know we all face inner
turmoil well face dilemmas you know
because you have to feel these things to
create characters and then you begin to
understand that you know the people that
you're sitting in traffic with they're
just as stressed out as you are I think
this is the fascinating thing about
right
it offers you this ability to take a
step back and understand people
understand your family your friends and
the people that you're passing by each
day on a deeper level but yeah I guess
then the next thing that I bring up is
just my process of writing here I write
every day just like any aspiring
filmmaker should or writer should I mean
obviously some days it's not possible
obviously some days I slip but you know
I'm not going to say I'm perfect by any
means but no as a college student it's
difficult my schedule is varying
constantly what it really comes down to
for me is just taking stock each and
every morning of the obligations that I
have in front of me in finding that
perfect time in no pun intended here but
finding the right time to write for that
particular day you know that's all I can
do and honestly it makes things a little
bit easier for me to take it day by day
like that I guess finally I'll talk
about this the goals for the script
obviously I'd love to see it in
production with the most important thing
for me is to have the script the script
teach me things you know the best thing
that it can do is be instructive to me
as I move forward as a writer it as I
begin to understand deeper what it means
to to create fascinating characters to
create compelling stories I'm going to
each day I need to be learning things
and that's kind of the most important
thing that the script can do for me and
just on the more broad level obviously I
want to get to a place where I can you
know invest all of my time and energy
into filmmaking into screenwriting you
know in creating and sharing stories
with people because ultimately you know
films have had such a powerful effect on
my life and I feel like it's time for me
to kind of share my own experiences for
me to kind of give back to the that
industry you know I feel so strongly
about you know trying to have the kinds
of emotional impacts that so many
wonderful filmmakers directors and
writers have had on me in the past you
know I want to contribute to that and I
want to get to a place where you know I
can sustain myself and dedicate all of
my time and
to that process because obviously you
know it you got it just like my
character in the story you know if you
can't stop thinking about something you
know you know it's for real and that's
kind of the place I'm at in my life but
again I want to thank you guys over at
film courage for this tremendous
opportunity I appreciate everything that
you do for us you know I've learned so
much from your channel you guys are
great and I want to thank you again and
I look forward to hearing from you soon